in which we have once again exceeded
expectations in the
unity
and single-mindedness
with which this alliance is confronting
putin's
illegal and barbaric invasion of
ukraine after 127 days of war
we in nato are now more resolved than
ever that europe's boundaries can't be
changed by force and that we must give
the ukrainians the means to protect
themselves and we are in the last few
days virtually everyone around the table
has agreed to give more
to help
and at the same time we have to
recognize that the impacts of this
brutal invasion of ukraine
are being felt around the world in
africa in latin america in asia there's
not a country that is not now being
affected by the surge in energy prices
the shortages of food and fertilizer and
so
just as we in the uk are focused on
helping people with the cost of living
1200 pounds going uh to next month in
july uh to the 8 million most vulnerable
households with more help to come 400
pounds for every family to help with the
cost of energy
so to the governments of the of the
commonwealth of g7
and of nato
are determined to work together
to ease can you hear me
can you pick it up roughly
yeah
i'm just gonna have to i'm just gonna
protect so to the governments of the
commonwealth g7 and nato are determined
to work together
to ease the pressure around the world
whether that means kicking the train out
of ukraine or encouraging moves to
increase global energy supplies or
helping countries to find alternative
supplies of fertilizer
and we must frankly recognize the risk
that not every country
of putin's invasion or sees it in the
way that we do so we've agreed together
to work to explode some myths
we have to explore the myth that western
sanctions
are in some way responsible for these
price fights but of course it is the
russian uh invasion that has caused the
uh shortages of food and uh and it is
putin's blockades uh that are stopping
uh the the grain leaving uh ukrainian
courts we need to to explode the myth
that it was in any way
nato that had responsibility for
provoking the conflict nothing could be
further from the truth if you want proof
that nato is a purely defensive alliance
you could have no more eloquent
testimony than the accession of finland
and sweden
quintessentially
peace-loving countries that have been
neutral
for decades and uh the fact that these
two
paladins for peace have joined nato
tells you all you need to know about
nato and all you need to know about
putin
we need to show the global south that we
are the partners they need that we nato
countries uh other partners they needn't
and that we're there to help them
as they make the transition to a green
future and that they should beware the
trap by the way of running up huge debts
to other countries that do not share our
values and and maybe do not have their
best interests at heart
and the final myth
we need to debunk
is that when it comes to a crisis
like this
western democracy because of the
pressures that politicians face do not
have the same
staying power
and
i think that if ukraine were to be
crushed or forced into a bad peace the
consequences for freedom around the
world would be appalling and that view
is shared by everyone in nato so let's
be absolutely clear
the best way for us to win the argument
around the world about our values what
we stand for
about our opposition to the use of force
to change boundaries about the the
primacy of of international law the best
way to win that argument is for the
ukrainians to win
and for putin to fail in ukraine
and that's why i'm pleased today that
we've announced another billion pounds
worth of military support
and if you wanted evidence of the
amazing ability of the ukrainians to
fight back to overcome adversity and to
repel the russians and look uh what has
happened uh just today on snake island
where again
russia has had to cede ground
in the end it will prove impossible for
putin to hold down a country that will
not accept his rule
this has been a crucial summit in that
we are resolved not just to support
ukraine but we've agreed a new strategic
concept where
we're moving uh additionally beyond the
doctrine of tripwire deterrence uh on
nato's eastern flank to a new approach
of defence deterrence by denial
and
countries around the table are also
recognizing that they need to spend more
and in our case that means meeting and
being prepared to exceed the target we
set for ourselves a decade uh ago of
everybody spending two percent of gdp on
defense
the goals that were then set for a very
different era and what we're saying is
that we want yens uh stoltenberg the
secretary general uh to start work on
that new target now and and he's agreed
to do that
we need to invest for the long term in
vital capabilities like future combat
air while simultaneously adapting to a
more dangerous and more competitive
world and the logical conclusion of the
investments on which uh we propose to
embark uh of these decisions is that we
will reach 2.5 percent of gdp on defence
by the end of the decade
i want to say
a big thank you to our to our spanish
hosts i think they've done an amazing
job i want to thank against stoltenberg
and my view is at the end of this madrid
summit the nato alliance is plainly in
robust health
and getting stronger with new members
and a renewed purpose we can see that
our work is cut out and we can see that
there are billions of people around the
world
swing voters who need to hear and to
understand our arguments
but we have a huge advantage of knowing
what we want in believing in our ideas
and having the means to do what we want
to do
and above all
we are united and if history is any
guide then i believe that this great
alliance will again be successful
thank you all very much and i'd like to
go to the media where we i think we've
got question first from chris mason the
bbc
thank you chris mason bbc news prime
minister what is the overall objective
of the uk's health and strategy for
ukraine is it unequivocally getting the
russians out restoring ukraine's borders
to how they were before the war
and if i may you've been out of the
country for eight days are you actually
looking forward to returning home given
the ongoing speculation about your own
future
on the second point yes i can't tell you
how much i'm looking forward to get not
that i've been wonderful being here in
madrid
as you want uh as you need i enjoyed
being in kigali and and germany uh but
uh you know uh there's no place like
home so i'm i'm i'm keen to get back uh
on on your point about where we're
trying to what the what the um
what's the what's the go we can't be
more ukrainian than the ukrainians
everybody understands that it's for it's
for vladimir zelensky uh his
uh people to uh to decide what they what
they want to do whether whether they
want to uh to cut a deal with uh with
russia to make some kind of piece of
course that's entirely a matter
for them though i noticed that after the
attack on the shopping center i think i
saw a poll saying that 89
of uh ukrainians uh would under no
circumstances uh contemplate a a a a
land for peace deal so you know i can
see that the difficulties in in ukraine
our job is simply to vindicate the
principle to stand up for the principle
of the right of the ukrainians to
protect themselves that's what we're
doing that's what everybody in the
alliances is doing
and uh we want to give them the means to
repel the uh the russians to expel uh
the russians from the territory that
they have occupied because that is the
right thing under international law and
as everybody has said uh we want at the
very least to put zolensky in the best
possible position uh he could be in if
and when he decides that there is
anything to talk about but at the moment
let's be absolutely clear
there doesn't seem to be anything to
talk about because it's not only that
the ukrainian people would find it very
difficult to do a deal
putin isn't even offering a coup and a
right to continue to support a ukraine
in the way that we are and indeed to
continue to to intensify that military
support because i think that they do
have the potential to turn this round uh
we've seen what ukraine can do
uh to drive the russians back we've seen
what they did around kiev around kharkiv
now on snake island i think the right
thing for us is to keep going on the
course that nato has set out no matter
how difficult uh it
but that's what this summit has
certainly agreed
romney weeks of itv
i'll shout too
prime minister the american assessment
is that the war in ukraine could drop
grind on for an extended period of time
do you really think you've won the
argument amongst fellow leaders to
support ukraine to the bitter end and do
you think you can sustain an appetite
for that back home
so romney i think
it's a
i think the argument here at nato uh the
argument at g7
is very very clear and everybody i think
is there's a great deal of unity
uh around this around this table
everybody can see the point of principle
but everybody can see the practical
consequences for the world it would be
disastrous if uh if putin were to
succeed in in ukraine so there's a
the there's a strong unanimity here i
think when it comes to
the the the global congregation
yeah i mean the interesting thing uh uh
in the last few days and weeks has been
to listening to other voices some of
whom i think are under a misapprehension
about what is really going on uh about
who's to blame for the spikes in uh in
fuel prices uh uh
under misapprehension about what nato
really is i'm afraid that we have to
recognize
that uh we have to do more as an
alliance as well
to counteract some of the the propaganda
that's coming out from the other side
and and we have to be humble about that
we have to recognize that not everybody
is necessarily automatically going to
see it our way first time i think the
arguments are with us i think we'll win
the argument but we need to we need to
make it
uh hugo guy from the eye
uh thank you prime minister you talk
about needing to win over
other countries
uh who are worried about the war's
economic consequences are you at all
concerned that people back at home who
are struggling from high inflation which
is exacerbated by
the war are also going to gain
sort of ukraine fatigue if you like and
what would be your message to them
and
on a similar topic
hmrc has reported today that 6.1 million
people in the uk are now paying higher
rate tax you've consistently promised to
bring down tax rates but in many ways
they're higher than ever
when will you bring down tax rates will
it be this year
yeah so hugo the point i would make
about the the the cost of
a freedom as it were is that actually it
is always worth paying
unless we we get the right result in
ukraine putin will be in a position uh
to commit further acts of aggression
against other parts of the the former
soviet union more or less with impunity
that will drive further global
uncertainty further oil shocks further
uh panics and more economic distress for
the whole world and the lesson of the
last century of the 20th century is that
things are only really sorted out and
you only really have a long period of
sustained uh prosperity when you uphold
the rules-based international system and
when borders aren't changed by force so
that's the point i would make to uh to
people about
what we're trying to do here and i think
people do get that and they do see how
important it is uh and then on your
point about taxation don't forget hugo
that next month we've got uh
tax cut worth 330 pounds on average uh
for households uh oh sorry for all
payers of national insurance uh
contributions are coming in a very
substantial tax cuts a tax cut
in addition to what we've done on fuel
duty and on council tax of course uh you
know we always want to try to reduce
burdens but we have to
do it in a sensible and a responsible
way
uh
chris smith of the times
[Music]
the struggle uh more than others
inflation is going to stay high for a
very long time you've talked a lot about
how this is going to abate fairly
soon are you at risk of being complacent
about inflation do you need to do more
to deal with the fallout of this war so
i i think we have to recognize that the
uk is exposed to two particular types of
of issue we've got very very low
unemployment which means we have by
comparison with uh a lot of other
countries around the table which means
got a very very tight labor market uh
which which has a an inflationary
pressure and our the balance of our
energy mixes is also uh difficult at the
moment uh we have to deal with uh those
issues we've got to deal with a lot of
the underlying causes of of cost
pressures for for people for businesses
for the whole country and so
we've got to help people in the with the
costs with the 1200 pounds all the other
help that we're we're giving help
helping people with trying to to get
through the price bike but you've also
got to try to look at the root causes
and i think there are things going on in
the uk economy whether it's in the the
housing market or the energy market uh
our transport systems which are driving
the way government spends money uh which
are driving unnecessary cost pressures
for people uh in our country and those
are the things that we need to to fix as
part of our plan for a stronger economy
so i i i chris you know you're basically
in no way minimize the the
importance of this but nor do i minimize
this is a big chance for us now to do
things differently and do things better
and uh and create foundations for for a
much stronger economy
ben glaze the mirror
minister thank you um why are you still
cutting 99 000 troops and british army
and why are you breaking a manifesto
pledge to spend half percent above
inflation on defense spending
well ben if you look at what we're doing
with the
uh british army i think most fair mighty
people ask jen stoltenberg which is the
country uh that's really committing
defense uh spending to nato which is the
country that's contributing uh the most
uh to creating the right uh level of
investment for the west alliance it is
the uk and i think we're now spending uh
last year we spent the third
biggest amount on defense of any country
in the world in 2021 uh we've increased
defense spending by 24 sorry 24 billion
pounds uh in the in the latest uh
spending run
and and if you look at uh what we're
doing uh
right now we're well over the two so on
the point three uh percent uh we're at
two point three percent now
and uh you will have heard what i've
just said about uh the logical if you
protract what we're doing on um
on orcas uh on fcas uh you know we're
gonna get to 2.5 by the end of the
decade
yeah look i mean i i i i hear that i
just think that the the the most
important thing
is to have uh armed forces armed
services that are
brilliantly equipped superbly able to do
the jobs that they need we have the best
troops in the world but i want them to
have the kit that they need and
i want them to have the kit that they
need
harry cole son
thank you uh prime minister um after you
took the mick out of putin at the g7 for
posing topless i regret to inform you he
has hit back
he said that if you did the same it
would be a disgusting sight and western
leaders should stop abusing alcohol and
other bad habits do physical exercise
and take part in sports
one are you going to take that would you
like to respond and secondly do you
really think it's wise to pick up a war
of words with a man your own government
calls a lunatic with a very large
nuclear arsenal i think the most
important conclusion that
uh that vladimir putin needs to draw
from what's happened uh today uh last
few days in in uh in nato and then
previously in the g7 is that we are
totally united in uh condemning what
he's done in ukraine uh we're resolved
to uh do everything uh that we can to
help the ukrainians to repel his troops
and i think that's the thing that uh
he should think about
i think that
that's he should think about uh the
consequences of his barbaric actions uh
the
uh the way it has uh his invasion has
actually brought the the west together
nato g7 eeu look at look at the way uh
people have come together
and
if he wanted you know less nato on his
borders uh by getting into uh in into
ukraine which by the way was it wasn't
it was never remotely likely that
ukraine was going to join uh nato any
time uh in the foreseeable future
everybody knew that it was completely
mythical but instead what he's got
is um
sweden and finland are breaking their
historic vows
of neutrality
because they're so appalled and repelled
by his violence and his aggression
and i think that's a that is that is an
absolutely devastating comment on
on what he has done and his behavior
jasmine cameron celestia vft
thank you prime minister earlier this
week foreign secretary liz trust called
china an aggressor and she said that the
west had been complacent over china do
you agree with her assessment do you
think the uk needs to re-examine its
relationship with china
look i think on on china
it's very important that we
uh
remember that we have to uh we have a
huge economic relationship with china so
does every every country around that
table america's got a gigantic free
trade deal uh with china but at the same
time we've got to understand that there
are areas in which uh we need to
compete uh contest and uh sometimes
challenge what china is up to
and that that is clear and
we had a long discussion in the uk as
you'll remember about about huawei it
was very difficult it was very painful
but in the end
there was just a limit to the
the way economic uh into into
penetration could uh could go and we
have it it it clashed with the our need
for
national security and so we had to fix
that and uh what we're doing around the
world is uh is making sure that we we
have that balance and uh that we stand
up to china uh wherever uh is necessary
and i think you know
but be also being realistic you know it
is very very important that we
understand that china is a is a a great
country it's going to be a gigantic fact
of uh the world's economy for a long
time to come
so you need to
there has to be a
balanced approach and every and every
country
around that table can see that but
obviously one of the reasons why uh what
is happening in ukraine is so important
is because there is a clear read across
to other theaters and uh
that's why we're sticking up for the the
rules based international system in the
way that we are i mean obviously we're
sticking up for it in ukraine because
it's overwhelmingly the right thing to
do but there's also a reader cross
spanish media and antenna three sarah
romero
uh prime minister thank you for the for
the floor uh how important is the
southern flank of north africa for nato
and will nato defend celta and malia in
case of aggression thank you
thank you uh listen sarah that's a that
uh on your specific question about
serotonin that's a brilliant point
i don't think i have the answer to that
in the uh because i mean i know that the
the two uh
i i i think is enclaves the right word i
don't know what how to express i mean i
i'm vaguely aware of their
constitutional status but i i i would
hesitate to to offer a doctrine on
on on
the extent to which they're comprised
within the article five guarantees that
that doesn't mean there isn't an answer
it just it just means that uh
unfortunately sarah i i i don't know
what the answer is if there's spanish
territory if it's held that they're
spanish territory then i imagine uh that
they're protected under article five
okay let me let me go as far as to say
that right
um
on your wider point about the maghreb
and the north african literal i think
there's a big agenda for nato and i
think we should be and we should be
thinking about it and i think one of the
mistakes the big strategic mistakes that
that we made as europeans is not to
recognize uh that
that is the origin of so much of the
migration so much of the uh of the of
the turmoil and and problems in north
africa feed back into the into the sahel
and make things worse so there's a
negative feedback loop so i'd be in
favor of uh a much greater engagement uh
with with all those areas and uh so
and definitely a a project for nato uh
sergey sidorenko of european prague
uh thank you prime minister i'm here
here
not to be confused by the way with com
somalskaya probably right absolutely
absolutely i can see some snickering
from there you can recognize me by
zalenski type t-shirt exactly
first of all i i would like to thank you
and to the uk uh for the support for
ukraine that we are really enjoying and
you are i would say even leading uh
military support for us
but at the same time and also i would
like to thank you for revolt that
ukraine have to define its future and
victory and ukraine did uh
even president zelinski i have said
these days that we are going and we need
to win this year
not not to be that much involved in the
world do you see a real chance
for ukraine to win
considering uh that
nato allies are not so uh happy to
provide us
so needed our weaponry because we see no
modern tanks no
jets and so on
maybe you see some ways to do that in
that time frame and also even more
important
as you said just now that uh no one did
expect to see a ukraine in nato uh which
is said to hear about uh now is there a
challenge is this being realistic there
yeah but is there a chance to
to become a a member of nato one day
after ukraine wins or or nato is still
that much afraid of russia that cannot
even uh think of it okay because there
is no other yeah well that thank you
look i mean that's that's really good uh
so the the reason i went to thank you
very very much sergey so the reason i
went to to ukraine shortly uh before the
all these summits began was really i
wanted to get a real feel for uh for
where uh president zolensky and his
administration were and how they saw
things going
and
it really is clear as you as you say
just now
they do see a way in which they can
change the dynamic this year in the next
few months
and
i think that's important and i think it
means we have to to help them as much as
we can because they've shown that they
can resist they can show their amazing
amazing ability uh to fight back that's
why i think the most interesting recent
development has been the mlrs the
multi-launch rocket systems which have
been going to to ukraine and i'm told
that ukrainian troops are proving very
adept in in using them
uh now we've we've got to make sure that
that's right and that uh the ukrainian
troops heroic as they are are getting
the maximum value out of the the stuff
that we're uh that we're able to to send
uh but
we think
that they do indeed have it in their
power uh to to repel the russians and
and and to get them uh back to the po to
the pre-february the 24th uh position
and and that is that's certainly what uh
what vladimir says he wants to do and he
set out a plan uh for for doing that now
uh as for the as for the
the
ultimate solution for the for ukraine's
presence in the security security
architecture of europe it's clear to me
what should then happen
it's clear to me that leaving aside
the question of an article 5 guarantee
what you have what you should have is
the
the western powers
whether all of nato or just some nato
countries
should be
offering deterrence by denial
so that we
so
fortify a ukraine with nato grade
weaponry
plus intelligence plus training
that no future attack is
conceivable that's that's stage one and
that's that's the that's the position
that we want to uh to get to and i think
that that will prove to be uh
a very very effective solution there can
then be a further argument down the
track about uh about nato but it that
would be my my interim uh my interim
solution okay everybody i was i've i was
told to be no more than nine thank you
see you later thank you
that was boris johnson there speaking at
the nato summit in
madrid he talked about historic summits
uh the invasion of ukraine by russia was
felt around the world no country he said
was not affected by shortages of food
and fertiliser directly to stress there
was a need to explode the myth that nato
was responsible for the war in ukraine
it's impossible to hold a country he
warned vladimir putin that will not
accept russian rule uh also he said the
nato alliance was of robust strength and
getting stronger and of course we know
that
finland and sweden are going to
sign up if ukraine was forced into a bad
peace consequences that would be felt
around the world
said the prime minister he also talked
about defense spending must recognize
the risk that other countries don't take
the same view of putin's invasion of
ukraine as we do he said countries
around the table recognizing they need
to spend more that means spending more
than two percent of gdp on defense he
said britain spends two point three
percent now but that will
reach two and a half percent by the end
of the decade
[Music]
foreign